nawel j'aimerais qu'on fasse un petit
concours de danse nawal j'étais choisi
son partenaire sam est riche en inscrit
par oui ah ouais ben c'est normal
les deux invités vous allez danser tous
les deux et vous mais non mais moi je
danse après moi vous voulez que je
dansais cloud les deux animaux ça pas
moi qui voulais danser mois les bases et
richard nadal et richard c'est parti
nawel on est ce que tu veux comme
musique tu veux quoi un son que j'écoute
en ce moment c'est moi tu dois je pense
en ce moment parce qu'elle est énoncée
c'est pas les gones battle de danse vous
êtes en chambre et après l'animal
dansera avec une des premières et par
contre dans un prénommé à tanger pas
mettre ce genre de sommet va se frotter
[Rires]
à dubaï ici ça dans un fossé
est ce que tu veux que je le fasse
d'abord dit non mais si la sortie
un cyril avec toi qui me lis c'est kelly
ou isabelle je crois que ces coups de
[Applaudissements]
canon cgt
isabelle n'a rien on peut pas tricher
normalement c'est toi
quoique ça tient début du temps la
visite allait super ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais t'es autre chose je vais partir
de là toi tu es tranquillement sur la
piste et je vais venir aussi dans la vie
non mais toi là tu commences à danser
tout et tout cela pour l'instant je vais
arriver
envoyez là mais l'agent d'impôts contre
map
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]